[Musik]
video mit tito und marlon rosenpark in
der bild am sonntag wir sind back on
track tolle farben alles
inneneinrichtung ist eigentlich noch
grün blau töne bestimmen die das
raumkonzept und vista das restliche haus
ist eine terrakotta hölle und das wäre
etwas brauchst du dich sehr gemein wenn
dein zimmer auch die terrakotta hölle
während jetzt noch mal damit den nicht
vergessen große ist mach dich mal
wirklich grund
ich war ungefähr so groß weil ich mal im
vergleich zu q4 open mich eben hier und
ist perfekt dass wir hier drehen in
mailand gerade schon versucht unten zu
drehen aber die sonne kommt immer
richtig krass wie das fenster durch und
deswegen haben wir gesagt haben wenn
dann lieber hier ist dunkel sondern kann
wie viel können hier
[Musik]
eigentlicher tisch perfekt denn wir
werden heute einen kalender tasten mit
knete also magic wird auf nähte ich hol
dir mal ich hab vergessen nichts
also ich weiß nicht was magic dass ich
habe ja schon den schleim
adventskalender ausprobiert das war mein
erstes mal leise der hisense kalender
sind der marke grace es ist nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle zusammen lisa
dasteht magic so intelligent jetzt
machen wir auch wir fahren mit dem
kirche habe ich an deinem übungs tisch
sind ja jetzt kalender aufmachen damit
du meine karriere fortführen kann vor
[Applaus]
augen führen oder stange dein neuer
magic duo zuckerstangen mit farbwechsel
effekt und erdbeer duft freudig auf die
kommenden tage und die verschiedenen
mehlsorten also wohlgemerkt noch mehr
einmal als ich zeig' einmal ich hoffe
man sieht ein bisschen war sie insgesamt
19 eur 95 kosten
ich bin so gespannt wie hofer gucken
also es kommt so in seiner ware ankommt
[Musik]
ich hatte einmal raus irgendwie hätte
jetzt die seite fest ja dann hältst du
die seite fällt ja wie
st na ja da waren aber die ist
irgendwann irgendwie weiter vorgestellt
die ist aber so können wir so nah so
[Musik]
wechselt schon die farbe kniete macht
einfach spaß verstehe ich was ist mit
kniet auf sicherheit achten
irgendwie so jetzt in bakterien daran
jetzt hat das wieder zu und alles fertig
genauso wir machen weiter mit 272 pixel
deiner deine eigenen magic sword mit
dieser farbe mischen die fahren
vorsichtig in kleinen mengen dass das
gewünschte ergebnis erreicht ist
wir müssen halt diesen knet haufen hier
wir müssen diesen farben zusammen
finde neue magic die kreationen und
erzeuge tolle effekte indem du deine
magic tor mit perlen
also hier haben wir jetzt wieder gerade
eigentlich gesagt dass ich deine perle
bin also nicht so hier meint wir sind
geschwister oder handy komponierte
findet ihr unten links
kraft habe kreiere deinen eigenen magic
damit cool metallic-look menschen ist
das gewünschte farbe ganz erreicht ist
ein großes team geht ob jürgen großmann
als dir was da drin ist
dunkles grünen glitzer mixa deinen
eigenen magic dauernden letzter folien
doppeltes ja wir brauchen wir müssen
mehr knete weil wir haben noch so wenig
das ist so ein stück goldfolie
schokoladenfabrik von charlie
[Musik]
okay es ist eine folie nicht mal zum
fühlen gehen weil sieben damit sie nicht
weil sie sonst nicht begonnen haben
diesen goldmann
man kann das find ich hatte mal ich habe
jetzt diesen knet ba und den habe ich
jetzt kommt mit dem blattgold um
gewickelt und wenn man dafür drückte
dann dann das ist mal befriedigend
die abreisen pop worten papiers ist das
sehr schön das ist richtig gut dass man
wissen dass gold die litauen cranes ich
hoffe dass kein echtes holz natürlichen
nummer 78 der ok das wollen wir nicht
kannten
weil wir so zwei als ich hier sind jetzt
so zwei augen drin
mein gott dieser hohen genau zwei augen
dran da vida
vielleicht machen wir ja und dann haben
wir wieder magic dann packen wir auf
unsere magic kaufen weil ein großes
schaffen wir werden die weltherrschaft
übernehmen
wir versuchen die weltherrschaft an uns
zu reißen wir kommen nicht weiter die
nummer 8 oder etwas langes drin ist noch
was drin
ich weiß es nicht
werkzeuge für die knete mit dem weg zu
überdenken
das ist so dass rolf e
damit kann man so quasi als rasierte
reichhaltig altes gerät gut fest
ein christlicher kanal haben
wie du sagen war groß
nein doch es sind wunsch der sterbe- und
stift gestalte deine eigenen
verpackungen für deinen verschiedenen
sorten von mexiko ich liebe diesen
adventskalender günstig und ja und
buntstifte und du kannst diese sticker
anmalen
bekleben allgemein und gerade mal 99
haben sich leute wirklich gedanken
gemacht
oh mein gott hier sind zwei mal welche
zwei magic dort drin leute die doppelte
gehandelte spaß leuchtet im dunkeln
bringe deinen magic duo im dunkeln zum
leuchten lade deine magic und pflicht
auch das heißt man kann wieder halbiert
also dass die turner wie es knistert
wenn du damit spielt sollen wir damit
spielen und klönen wildnis
ich habe das gefühl diese perlen sind
grundsätzlich sehr komisch aufgeladen
aufgenommen nämlich ja die fliehen alle
richtungen zwei mal wie es knistert höre
zu ich habe kein knistern meyer die
schuhe
da weißt du 1 unser perlentaucher toller
plan sparen für zwei nach der 10 kommt
also das verstehe ich nicht der inhalt
ist wirklich an weihnachten angelehnt
hier haben wir zum beispiel ein link
machen
die brote und glauben nicht niemand
bräuchte jetzt eigentlich verrückt mit
der ich habe es gesagt das ist frischer
vertrauen
[Musik]
die teilweise kreiere deine eigene knete
mit witali klitschko
so nächste knete nach der 13
alarmstufe rot der neue magic dort ist
knallrot nixon kreiere damit die
variante mit dieser haben
rot-rot dem ries oft auch adam riese war
ein deutscher rechenmeister bekannt
wurde durch sein lehrbuch rechnung auf
der linie und feder nach der 15
jetzt haben wir ein tolles tool das ist
das gleiche wie immer aber das ist
flacher als das ist wie so quasi so
einen pizzaschneider so dass auf jeden
fall wenn ich mich fühle
dann kann ich meine karriere gleichen
die presse sie in 27 jährigen youtube
will kranken blinden groß zu folgendem
glinde bruder ab eine frage die anderen
kliniken aber nicht ganz normale knete
[Musik]
was kommt nach dem 17
sieh zu wie der transparente wer zu
langsam klar wird nachdem du mit ihm
gespielt hast also mit glas stehen würde
und das müssen wir jetzt kannst du damit
spielen
eine packung mit bunten perlen will ist
die bunteste perle die ich leider nicht
sehen kann aber findest du mein
charakter bund nicht ganz gleich alle
farben ein großes bundesschnitt geduld
zu haben
die kinder selber mit ihren sachen was
kommt nach der 22
der vorletzte tag strahlen schon ganz
aufgeregt
[Musik]
also heute
heute war ein kind sein und ich habe
richtig war solche chance nicht
bayerns trio explosion der farbe mischen
der farben zu einem einzigen großen
warum sie den adventskalender nicht
weihnacht nicht gestalten der weihnacht
wenn das jetzt so weihnachten vor allem
auch dazu im jahr
jetzt schön den ball in die hand den
ball in die hand an 34 arbeit rücken
oder bei uns ja
radio ja jetzt machst du die hand flach
noch mal gerne an brauchen wir gerade
auch dann kannst du die jetzt drückst du
in deinen händen soll ja dafür bekannt
von spaß dort zu kneten gibt mir mit der
genetik ball wird gedreht
[Musik]
die etwas weiter bedeckt
ich hab das gefühl hat und irgendwie so
einen komischen judt grau ist ähnlich
ist auch hat das abgleiten wir
verabschieden uns aktiven knete
adventskalender können wir sehr gut und
finden es war angenehm was dieser musste
viel spaß gemacht hat müssten auch uns
nie übergeben das ist ein großer
pluspunkt an dieser stelle an diesen
können
bis zum nächsten mal spendenkonto als in
der infobox
[Musik]